is the first it's my brained up
i'll start tonight with a sensational
story that a serving conservative member
of the british parliament has been
arrested under suspicion of rape sexual
assault indecent assault abuse of a
position of trust and misconduct in
public office
it's hard to imagine isn't it more
serious allegations about an elected
official not least because it's now
being reported that his alleged victim
is also a male politician 20 years his
junior who was a teenager when they
first met
it's self-evident in the public interest
that he'd be identified but absurdly he
remains anonymous until 2016 the speaker
of the house of commons was obliged to
tell parliament and therefore all of us
if an mp was arrested but the rules
changed because they were incompatible
apparently with a person's right to
privacy under the european convention on
human rights so although his name has
been plastered all over the internet
along with many innocent mps names all
i'm legally allowed to tell you is he's
a man in his fifties such as the feeding
frenzy about who it is some mps have
even made pathetic jokes about showing
up in parliament just to prove it's not
them
you think it's funny mr fabricant who
posted that the only funny thing here is
that you
make donald trump's hair look normal
but it's a serious matter the recent
spate of shocking sex scandals in
westminster
has been really quite disturbing isn't
it time and again week after week we
hear more and more salacious stories and
incredibly this arrested mp is delivered
to go to parliament if he wants to and
attend his constituency office think
about that for a moment his constituents
may come to him with their own stories
about the very things he's accused of
and have no idea
i believe in due process and innocent
until proven guilty but i also strongly
believe the people who voted for this
man deserve to know what's happened
naming him could also encourage other
possible witnesses or indeed victims to
come forward which has happened in many
previous similar cases boris johnson
this guy's boss
says he's shocked to learn of his
allegations well we all are prime
minister it makes a mockery of our
parliamentary process that we still have
no idea who this person is
the police and the conservative party
and you mr johnson should name him as a
matter of urgency
well being liberal used to mean
believing in free speech tolerance and
respect for those with different
opinions but today's woke version of
liberals seems hell-bent on behaving
like the fascists they claim to hate
don't take my word for it the world's
richest man elon musk one of the most
famous free speech advocates in the
world right now says he can no longer
vote for the democrats he's voted for
his entire life
and i i would trust myself as a moderate
and you know neither republican nor nor
democrat
and in fact uh i have voted vote
overwhelmingly for democrats uh
historically overwhelmingly like i'm not
sure
i might never have voted for a
republican just to be clear right now
now this election i would
well must let it took to twitter the
platform he's trying to buy of course to
help restore free speech and he said the
democrats have become his words the
party of division and hate and that he
now expects biblical attacks on him to
escalate well he was completely right he
was bombarded with abuse from the moment
he tweeted what he said about the
democrats and this afternoon he said
judging by the relentless hate stream
from the far left this tweet was spot on
it was and so is elon musk the very
people who claim to be the good guys
often with their ironic be kind hashtags
on their profiles are the same people
leading this vicious opinion purge they
just can't accept that people with
different views have any right to say
them they use abuse mob rule and
bullying to silence the shame opponents
or even hound them out of their jobs
this is not liberalism it's
authoritarianism defending free speech
has been sacrificed at the woke altar of
defending an increasingly ridiculous and
often imaginary group of gender
minorities as well as fellow wokies of
course try asking a regular voter on the
doorstep in britain in america in
australia what their pronouns are
they wonder what the hell you're talking
about
mine for the record are me myself and i
sadly liberals have shifted their hearts
from factories to faculties issues based
is now plant-based partisan is now
artisan it's supposed to be all politics
is local not locally sourced
the democratic party should be the
natural home of a genius innovator who
believes passionately in his country in
ideas and in free speech the fact is not
is another symptom of what musk calls
the woke virus please
somebody for the love of god develop a
vaccine against this before we all get
infected
so how do you solve a problem like a
soaring costly living crisis as millions
of people struggling to feed their
families and pay their bills
well there's proper sound management of
the economy of course increased
financial assistance for those who need
it even food banks for the most
desperate and starving people or
apparently we can just urge them to play
supermarket sweep
in a stunning interview the new police
watchdog andy cook seems to be
suggesting exactly that he told the
guardian also had to be the guardian
that a spiking crime is inevitable as it
cost the living surges adding i
certainly fully support police officers
using their discretion and the
shoplifting one's a good example isn't
it
well no it's not is it a cost of living
crisis doesn't mean we should start
means-testing crime it doesn't take a
detective to work out what would happen
next
kill maltaus as the policing minister
hastily went to the airways to
contradict that police chief but i'm
afraid i find it a bit old-fashioned uh
thinking um you know
we first of all believe that the law
should be blind um and police officers
should operate without fear or favor in
the prosecution of the law
but secondly also
that it's not quite right to say that as
the economy fluctuates so does
crime
so let me get straight we have one of
the senior cops in the country saying
poverty leads to crime and therefore
police should go soft on shoplifters
then we have the government minister
responsible for policing denying that
poverty leads to crime and instructing
police officers to enforce the law even
on the starving well guess what they're
both wrong
you want to know what happens when you
go soft on shoplifting go to california
where state law holds a shoplifting
below 950
is now de facto legal
inevitably this led to a spike in theft
smashing grabs organized looting even
the side of robbers bringing calculators
in stores to make sure they stand at the
limit think about that
and let's remember many of these
retailers are small businesses also
struggling to survive why on earth are
the police suggesting they should pick
up the bill for other people
the cost of living crisis is a serious
issue raising serious questions of our
leaders a free-for-all amnesty on
shoplifting and a descent into
lawlessness is not the answer
but i'd like to know i'm very sad to
report tonight the consequences of those
irresponsible words are already being
seen this is stephen seagull a brazen
shoplifting bird in devon england is
reported to have stolen more than 300
pounds worth of salted snacks from his
local supermarket apparently he's
mastered the automatic doors and raged
the shop three times a day
he apparently says when challenged the
security is gullible
well now quiz rounds if you can guess
what all these things have in common
taking the knee absorbing the ukrainian
flag over your social media profile
clapping for health workers
there you've got it they're all public
gestures made in support of very worthy
causes
and there are also causes that you'll be
vilified for not publicly supporting
for me they should all be a matter of
choice just because you don't do one of
these gestures it doesn't mean you're a
hateful uncaring bigot
footballer idrissa gay guy apologies
refused to play for his club paris
saint-germain last weekend reportedly
didn't wear a rainbow flex shirt in
support of lgbt rights
a guy is a devout muslim from senegal
where homosexuality is shamefully still
illegal
but that's besides the point footballers
shouldn't be compelled to wear symbols
for any political or social issues if
they don't want to nobody should
i remember being abused for not posting
a black square on instagram during the
blackout for black lives matter
following the death of george floyd it
wasn't because i didn't support the
calls i did it's that i didn't think the
stunt would make any difference and
unlike most of the rest of the internet
i didn't feel any urgent need to signal
my virtue before going back to posting
photographs of smashed avocados and my
legs on the beach if you did well good
for you but you can't force me to do it
and you shouldn't be abusing me for not
doing it and we shouldn't be forcing
footballers to do this kind of thing
either or abusing them when they choose
not to
you